i'll be helping all my exes i'll be
sending them money
really yeah but like you need money like
no let me not say that because they're
gonna start calling
hi i'm ali vigiano and i play leah
rousseau in the end of us and i'm derek
deblasis and i play tins i'm claudia
streppo and i'm a producer on the end of
us and i'm ben coleman i play nick my
name is gario de lorbe and i play hector
in the movie the movie's about two exes
having to quarantine together for a long
time and today we're gonna find out what
type of exes we are let's dive in what
would your last words be for your ex
take care of yourself you're gonna
regret this later it was fun while it
lasted the timing just wasn't right or
your loss yeah i would say take care of
yourself i don't i don't want to know
bad energy or give them about it i know
that's i'm all about just keeping good
vibes i'm picking take care of yourself
take care of yourself my my last words
take care of yourself yeah what's the
longest relationship you've ever been in
longer than all the options that i've
been given i'm gonna go three years i'm
thinking closer to five it's probably
like four and a half how long six years
i didn't know that yeah i'm gonna say
five just because that's the that's the
option i have for me it's three years
you've done four more than five yeah
like seven years holy crap
ever call your ex just for the sake of
drama all the time they need to know i'm
still mad i've thought about it but i
haven't done it i erased their number
actually i'm the one who has to put up
with those calls actually it's all the
time sad face we call each other to chat
but never when we're drunk that's mine
we actually talked to chat but never
when we're drunk i've erased like text
message conversations oh totally yeah
you're
like be able to go back and read it
teenage me would have probably done that
for sure oh i've thought of i've thought
about it but i haven't yet you've
thought about calling them but then
you've decided like no you're not gonna
do it what would you do if you ran into
your ex at a party say hello just to be
polite leave hide because they will
probably get really worked up about it
try to get closer to them play it cool
and chat with them to catch up on their
life give them a piece of my mind i
literally ran into an access party a
while ago and i was like
i have to be nice to their face okay hi
i wanna catch up i'm like yo what
happened how you been like how was your
life without me as you can see i'm
winning say hello yeah be polite yeah
i'm gonna say play it cool and chat with
them to catch up on their life the play
cool throws me off because it's like
because you are cool i guess that's it
choose a song dedicated to your ex i
don't listen to any of these music so
i'm not gonna know any of these songs
but i'm gonna just go off by the title
how many of these have you heard these
aren't none of them i've heard all of
them i think except for shout out to my
ex by little mix oh i will survive i'm
gonna say thank you next by ariana
grande i love thank you next i think
it's like the best breakup song ever and
it's like the best energy that and i
will survive are the only two that i
know on here you know irreplaceable by
beyonce you know it shout out to my ex
definitely there's no shout outs to noex
pick the gift you'd want for valentine's
day so we got roses we got chocolate we
got a dinner date we got jewelry we got
a massage we got hot sex
i mean what's not to like hot sex is
nice i'm in my 30s i'm more like i
appreciate a good conversation
in my 20s i'm like it's all about sex
baby i'm choosing between a massage and
a dinner date i've never had a massage
what i don't like strangers touching me
then that's then that's fair and i would
not recommend getting a massage sorry i
want dinner date and then a day of hot
sex but if you're going to dinner you
might as well have sex damn massage
sounds good too maybe to be different
i'll go with hot sex i like a good
dinner i love food i'm going to say a
dinner date we get our answer after you
click it click it
the one who stays friends oh i got the
bigger person what i want to be the
bigger person we can switch because i
i'm friends with most of my exes well we
all got different ones
all right this is so outrageously wrong
i don't know if i'm the bigger person i
got the bigger person so you get a
standing ovation for your emotional
maturity
you're well aware that you don't owe
anyone anything and that relationships
end sometimes that's great i got the one
who stays friends your partner was
somebody who mattered to you and you
appreciate them for who they are not
just because of what they had with you
you try to do everything to preserve
your friendship and to create a new kind
of relationship as long as you don't
cross those boundaries which is hard
sometimes it can work out great i'm the
one that got away it doesn't matter if
you broke it off or they did because the
fact of the matter is it's impossible to
get over you maybe it's your charm or
maybe it's the effort you put into
relationships but they never forget you
i'm like that is a fact and i got the
ghost relationship has an expiration
date you don't cling the whole let's be
friends thing doesn't work for you
that's so wrong i am maybe still hang on
to the past to a fault all right i don't
know about this quiz but thank you
buzzfeed and chris was dope i don't know
about them all right whatever and check
out the end of us coming soon
[Music]
you